ايش فيكم
للجمهوريين لكن البدايه تتعثرت فالرجل
الطامح في منصب نانسي فلوس كرئيس للاغلبيه
في مجلس النواب لم يضمن الرقم السحري وهو
فهم لا يعتبرونه
التي تسودها نظريات المؤامره
مفاوضات خلف الابواب المغلقه في اللحظات
الاخيره في محاولات لتفادي اجراء جوله
اعاده التصويت على اهم منصب للجمهوريين
استردوهم مناسب لوسي حيث لم يتم التصويت
على اختراع الاعاده منذ 100 عام كان هدف
في عام
بعواصف وانقسامات بين صفوف وكوادر الحزب
الجمهوري للسنوات القادمه
طيب طيب
في حزب الجمهوريه الجميع يعتبر نفسه
محافظا لكن السؤال هو اي نوع من المحافظين
هناك مثلا ما يسمى بتجمع الحريه وهم
الاكثر موالاه لدونالد ترامب داخل الحزب
وهم يعرضون مكارث وعندما تكون هناك اغلبيه
باربعه اصوات لا يمكن انتخابه بامتناع سته
نوابنا من حسبه
»
[تصفيق]
انشغال الجمهوريين بمعركه رئاسه الكونجرس
وتاخرهم عن فتح لجان تحقيق وعد بها سواء
كانت في الخروج الذي وصف بالمهين لاداره
بيض من افغانستان او ملفاتهم
وعلاقته مع شركات صينيه او حتى صلاحيات
الرئيس لاداره البلاد
[موسيقى]
خلافاتهم فعلى رئيس بيض التعامل مع كونغرس
المنقسم لاول مره ولم يستطيع تمريرا
مشاريع كبرى كما فعل على مدى العامين
السابقين لكن خلافات الجمهوريين تثلج صدر
الرئيس والديمقراطيه في القاهره